c'est d'abord à madrid et à londres que
sont apparues la semaine dernière les
premiers cas de variole du singe est une
maladie virale rats plus fréquentes en
afrique de l'ouest que dans les
capitales européennes nom est probable
que la transmission
quelques jours plus tard de nouveaux cas
se sont ajoutés en espagne et au royaume
uni mais également au portugal et aux
etats unis et maintenant celle ci à
montréal qu'on découvre une éclosion 1
date d'aujourd'hui on accueille dix sept
suspects dans le grand montréal 15 sur
l'île de montréal est on sûr la couronne
sud et la corée en main sur la couronne
nord de montréal
le premier quart montrer au 29 avril les
porteurs sont tous des hommes
homosexuels de moins de 50 ans qui ont
été infectés par échange de fluides
contaminés durant un contact rapproché
la variole du singe cause différents
symptômes visibles sur la peau mais sauf
exception et disparaissent après
quelques semaines on n'a pas paniqué à
l'échelle populationnelle on voit
clairement le ça prend des contacts
étroits donc en faisant votre épicerie
en prenant le métro et vos activités ya
pas de risque actuellement il n'y a pas
de traitement spécifique pour soigner
cette maladie nous voyons muni on
administre une dose du verset classique
contre la variole à titre préventif
le docteur pilarsky qui a deux porteurs
de ce virus parmi sa clientèle crois
qu'on devrait adopter la même stratégie
idéalement à mon avis ça aurait était de
vacciner tout le monde y est dans autour
de personnes qui sont déjà
atteintes qui sont déjà avec les
éruptions la maladie puis diminuer les
risques de transmission selon lui
l'apparition de ce virus dans un cercle
restreint de personnes n'est qu'un
concours de circonstances comme les
premiers la première personne c'est un
homme qui a des relations avec des
hommes donc j'imagine qu'ils aient un
contact avec des hommes d'où la
propagation à l'ormeau sexuelle
uniquement mais si c'était une femme
hétérosexuelle un homme hétérosexuel ça
aurait pu arriver aussi les virus il ne
choisit pas l'art ainsi choisi par
l'orientation sexuelle sexuelle ou le
sexe tout le monde
catane 2 cv riche la santé publique de
montréal tenu à rappeler que la variole
du singe ce n'est pas considéré comme
une infection transmise sexuellement et
que son mode précis de transmission
reste encore à définir ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal